des terres qui ont fait rêver tous les
explorateurs sur la côte est de
l'afrique un éden conquis par les lords
anglais au 19e siècle est devenu ensuite
terre de safari
le kenya et ses milliers de kilomètres
carrés de savane de forêt et sa faune
unique au monde incarne à lui seul ce
qui nous attire le plus en afrique
[Musique]
depuis une dizaine d'années
le pays mise énormément sur le tourisme
qui représente la troisième source de
revenus l'année dernière ce sont plus de
quarante mille français qui ont passé
leurs vacances ici
les touristes viennent par milliers les
prendre en photo dans des réserves
parfois saturé de 4,4 quand on parvient
à localiser un léopard c'est la foire
d'empoigné pour le prendre en photo
les l'odj pour millionnaires ces sites
incroyable implanté au milieu des
réserves à quelques mètres des éléphants
véritable arche de noé que vous pourrez
admirer depuis votre piscine
ce n'est que dans ce type de réserve
privée que l'on peut encore voir des
rhinocéros les animaux les plus rares du
continent il ne reste que 609 rhinocéros
noirs au kenya mais les braconniers les
tuent à coups de kalachnikov pour
découper leurs cornes revendus à prix
d'or sur les marchés chinois et si rien
n'est fait il risque tout simplement de
disparaître définitivement
elodie l'aventurière français se bat
contre ce massacre elle peut compter sur
sa petite armée privée cas unique au
kenya ces gardiens sont équipés d'armes
de guerre et de chiens spécialement
entraînés
ses rangers ce endroit de police c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent tuer les braconniers
qu'il traque jour et nuit
une criminalité qui touche aussi les
hommes
nairobi est surnommée la capitale du
crime en raison d'une hausse
spectaculaire des kidnappings dont le
terreau prend racine dans l'un des plus
grands bidonvilles d'afrique
à matar est un véritable coupe gorge
pour quiconque n'y a pas ses entrées
ils sont ici un million à s'entasser
dans des baraques de fortune parmi les
détritus et l'abu dhabi
long ville est contrôlée par le gang des
mungiki qui fait régner ici la terreur
pour tenter de rassurer les vacanciers
le kenya a donc mis sur pied une unité
de police pour les touristes des hommes
et des femmes qui sont supposés protéger
les abords des plus beaux hôtels de la
capitale pour la plus grande
satisfaction du manager de ce palace
la sécurité est primordiale pour nous il
faut qu'elles soient au top niveau quand
ils sont là autour de l'hôtel nous
sommes très confiants les clients
fortunés sont censés pouvoir sortir en
ville en toute tranquillité